I think this is a better way to describe
the ladies of the view this next clip
shows shows a certifiably crazy person
uh here is Whoopi Goldberg saying that
the government should shut down Fox and
that somehow the First Amendment doesn't
protect speech actually watch this I
have a question how come this is not
thought of as
being
recruiting how come they're not thinking
about it
why isn't why why is this not being
scrutinized the way that they scrutinize
other yeah well because to me this is
this should be against the law you
should not be able to lay to lie to the
America knowingly and you know it's one
thing if you made a mistake and you
didn't know but we heard for five or six
years how you know the media was a lion
sack of dude they were fake news they
were this so how come what is that what
is our what do we do as Americans to to
say this is not okay to the first
amendment I think you well I know my
first amendment doesn't allow you to
willingly lie
whoopee you human whoopee cushion yes
the First Amendment does allow you to
willingly lie you have lied and the
ladies that you sit next to have lied
about virtually everything for the past
five years very fine people on both
sides the covid vaccine Works no mandate
is coming Jesse Smollett was going to be
hanged we could continue you guys lie
about everything just in the last couple
weeks how many times have we played
things where you lie you lied about
don't say gay by the way we checked
yesterday on the show turns out no gay
people have been arrested in Florida yet
by saying gay or even a straight person
who might say gay you guys lied about
the AP uh African-American studies thing
you are allowed to lie because of the
first amendment I would prefer that
people like you on shows like that that
for some reason brainwashed NPC's watch
I would prefer that you didn't lie but
you are allowed to lie and I and I don't
want to put you in jail for lying okay
but again what she's upset about here is
that Tucker is real releasing more
information not hiding information you
may not like the results of it
okay you may not like the way he's doing
it but he's giving us more information
right not hiding information that is a
fundamental difference but the fact once
again that that woman gets up there on
that live television show that is the
number one rated show in daytime
television which is on at the exact same
time we do this so God bless you for
watching this instead of watching that
pure tripe okay uh but that she gets up
there and then literally she's telling
you you shouldn't be allowed to lie
while she's lying about the First
Amendment
huh
[Music]